hello everyone and uh welcome to another
most interesting game it's from round
seven of the super bets chess classic i
know you guys were expecting maybe a
game from round nine but the round nine
was not all that
eventful and this is uh one of the games
that i did not show and i really wanted
to show it to you guys because it's
simply incredible
uh before i forget congratulations to
england uh for beating croatia in the
uh uh in the football uh european
championship
i'm not not really a football football
fan myself but whenever there's a
european championship or world's
championship i watch that as pretty much
everyone watches that so you know i
i know what everyone is talking about uh
but
um yeah it was uh it was a very
impressive
display of skill uh so congratulations
on that
uh if any of you guys maybe follow
football and now that being said
let's uh check out this game so it's a
corona versus mamidyarov and it's
uh i don't know if it's the best game
it's we've seen so many great games here
because it's been a while since we've
been covering classical games but this
here is is truly a masterpiece so i know
you guys are going to enjoy it
and before we check it out i will even
include uh something that i haven't in
in some time a photo
from this event as uh some of you guys
still don't believe that this is
actually an over the board event uh here
you go
uh there's mamadara and fabi from round
seven courtesy of leonard otis
uh fabi with the white pieces and
usually uh when i see a photo of a chess
player or even two chess players
uh there will often be something weird
about the photo
it's very very rare that you see a photo
with two chess players that
there's nothing weird about it but this
photo i can't find anything odd
with this photo so maybe maybe you guys
could help him maybe you can
uh spot something uh like i said it's
it's incredibly unusual that
you know a photo where two chess players
are presented
has nothing wrong with it uh or
something it should be out of place
something should be weird but
i'm just not seeing it so maybe there's
a lot of you guys maybe you can spot
something that i'm missing here
so that being said let's check out the
game fabi has the white pieces and he
opens with
e4 and this is going to be this is going
to be a
brutal game right from the start with e5
by mommy jar of knight to f3
knights to c6 and bishop to b5 so just a
normal rue lopez for now we have knight
to f6
the berlin defense and now d3
uh we have bishop to c5 uh and now
knight to c3 and here
uh the usual way to play this is you
want to go d6 or you want to maybe
castle then
you know just continue developing with
normal moves but here mommy arrow goes
for knight to d4
and it's a very very rare idea it's seen
in in
a lot of openings like in the rubinstein
variation uh
for example uh but here uh it's
extremely rare only a handful of games
were
played with this exact same line and now
the problem is the light square bishop
is under attack and you don't
usually want to grab this and the the
way black wants to play this is to
allow white to capture the spawn d6 push
away the knight back and then bishop to
g4 to pin the knight as the knight is
already under attack but fabi not
interested in going for that
uh bobby just retreats with the bishop
uh with bishop to a4 there is one
interesting game uh wesley so played it
against um
dominguez perez in the saint louis
champion showdown in 2017 that uh
was again very interesting and the line
basically goes knight captures on e5
black will castle and then just bishop
back to c4
d6 and now white will sacrifice here on
f7 rook captures bishop captures king
captures and now h3
and this is now although white is down
upon white is down a piece white is up
two pawns and the white
should be better here but in this one
notable game between two very strong
grandmasters
black was victorious so it's hard to say
if uh if this is uh good or bad because
there there's no
uh uh there are no actual games between
uh very strong players in this opening
and uh well in this one one instance
black just one so here
like i said fabio avoids all of this and
after knight to d4 he just sidesteps
with the bishop bishop to a4
and now there is one game where queen
the e7 was played but here we have c
c6 and it is already and now already as
of move six that we have a completely
new game
so let's see what mamadar prepared here
and
this is i think exactly what he wanted
to do it's uh have a
completely new game so early on get fabi
completely out of his preparation and
then try and uh
do some damage with the black pieces so
here we have castles
uh by fabi and now d6 uh and only now
fabi grabs this knight because now
bishop to g4 is coming
you do not want to allow this and h3
might be
that might be unnecessary if you if you
don't need to play it so here
knight captures on d4 bishop captures on
d4 and
now h3 and here fabi says i've sold all
of my problems
not much you can do here it's just a
very nice position
for white and you know i'm just going to
continue playing this however
and you know that's a double exclamation
mark however uh
majora plays g5 here and this is just
fabi knew here that he ran into some
serious preparation
and uh that's why i've decided to put
this position on the thumbnail
now he he he wants to play g4 he wants
to open up the position play rook g8 and
put some pressure uh
to the white king and this bishop here
is just a monster uh
as you'll see later in the game and it's
not a great move because there is
one way that you that white can play
this and um
well just not get shattered but it's uh
it's a move you might not
think of at first so uh feel free to
pause the video already here to find
the basically the only refutation of
this g5 move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not grabbing
the
pawn uh and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
knight to d5 this is the move that
allows the whites to
to keep the the advantage and uh well
just say that
uh okay sorry about
sorry about that i had to check if it
was uh if it was any urgent baby stuff
uh but luckily it's not so after knights
to d5 uh what do you play here
well uh you cannot capture with c
captures on d5 so you could capture with
the knight that doesn't really do
anything
so you might continue with the attack
after rook to g8 but now
c3 and this is the point after the
bishop retreats now we eliminate the
dark square bishop and
that's it there is no more danger from
this diagonal white will capture and
now bishop to b3 and here you don't have
to worry about uh
you have to worry a little bit but
there's nothing that black can do to
actually
cause damage if g4 you're just going to
play h4 if you're going to go knight to
h5 try and
uh for example grab the pawn just g3 and
white is white is
incredibly uh solid here so after this
g5 move
fabi did not play knight to d5 he played
knights the e2 but now
uh you can't really do it like this
because now this bishop will be a
monster for the rest of the game
and mamadarov uses it uh with the deadly
purpose here he goes back bishop to b6
now c3 of course you want to play d4 at
some point and block
this diagonal and now rook to g8
we have d4 by fabi just uh
getting rid of this bishop or maybe if
only temporarily but
uh getting rid of it at least for now uh
but
at the price of the e4 pawn so mamijaro
grabs it
and now bishop back to c2 so you give up
the pawn
this bishop again comes alive now you
can't really move the knight otherwise
you're gonna lose the h7 pawn
so d5 defending the knight and here
bishop captures an e4
we have d captures and now d captures an
e5 and here fabi says all right
uh you had your fun the attack is over
let's trade queens and uh
okay i'm out of the woods uh but
mamadirov says
nope he just trades queens captures
captures and
now plays g4 and again what do you play
here
now of course you cannot allow the g
file to be open so h4
and now g3 and this was the point
of it all now the pawn cannot capture
the bishop like i said a monster here
and the knight cannot capture
uh due to the same reason we just
captured the the knight and the pawn
still can't capture the pawn is pinned
so after g3 we have knight to d4 now
blocking the bishop on b6 but now
again not rushing with capturing this
but rather bishop
back to d8 mommy they are playing this
like a machine
uh now saying okay i'm just gonna
capture this and then i'm gonna capture
this while the bishop is protecting it
so fabi has the capture on g3
we have captures rook captures and now
rook to e1 going after the pawn
and now while you could grab the h4 pawn
there's even a stronger move and that is
rook to g4
now you're defending this pawn you are
now ready to capture this pawn
and uh there's only one thing fabi can
do bishop to g5 you keep the pawn alive
like this mommy daryl grabs the bishop h
captures on g5 and now again not going
for this and allowing this capture this
e4 pawn is incredibly important not only
is it a pass pawn but it's really just a
nice nice bone in white's throat
so here kink the e7 now we want to
develop the bishop and bring the other
rook over to the g
file and it's not even about the pawn
you just want to open up the g
file for your rooks to attack the white
king so here rook 8 to d1
now fabi has some ideas of maybe knight
b3 knight c5 then put pressure
along the d file bishop to d7 and
now uh what do you play here well fabi
is an incredibly strong guy especially
in classical and he's a very very
resourceful guy
and here he plays e6 and now what do you
play here his hope is that
mamijarov captures with the bishop and
now if knight captures an e6f captures
we have
rook to d4 with a double attack on the
pawn and that's it he
can somewhat equalize for example rook
g8 we're going to capture here
we're going to trade rooks here and uh
of course rook captures here and
you're down upon but uh fabi is very
comfortable playing this position uh
being down upon so here instead after e6
fabio
uh mamidaro of course keeps his uh
uh uh bishop on the board he plays f
captures on e6
and now comes fabi's real idea and that
is g6
that's the the point now if rook
captures you can eliminate this pawn
and then you're you know back back in
the game but not uh not what the mahmoud
had in mind he
plays h captures on g6 uh and now he's
up two pawns but at least
favi was able to close off uh the g file
which was his
actual actual plan all along so here we
have knight to b3
now preparing to shift the knight over
to c5 to do some damage here but now
e5 uh making room for this bishop to be
developed here and then you will be
uh defending this pawn very nicely so
here if you go knight to c5
with with this plan then bishop to f5 uh
and
there is nothing much that white can do
you're defending the d7 square
and of course if captures here then rook
b8 just wins the game
the knight has to move or you know
you're just going to lose it knight to
c5 rook captures here and that's it
mamadirov just wins this
so instead after e5 we have knight to a5
now going after the pawn like this but
it's not much better
and fabi really doesn't have a a you
know
a better move so here bishop to e6
now fabi was not interested in this he
just wanted to bring the knights to c4
to kind of activate it like this but
mamadourov says nope that's not
happening
we have rooked the d8 now with ideas of
doubling up either on the d
or on the e file to start getting rid of
these doubled pawns as
double pawns are easy targets for the
rooks but now rook to b8
seemingly a weird move but it does
it really does a lot it really uh
keeps this knight on a5 and the knight
now really doesn't have all that many
squares where where the knight can go to
you can try bringing it back to b3
but then we're going to play b6 and
again the knight will not have uh
any squares it's just going to be a very
very sad night so there there's time to
worry about that knight
favi starts by b4 he wants to play a4
and then try and bring the knight back
into the game
king to f6 uh now improving the position
of the king
and now a4 we have rook to g3 now the c3
pawn has been weakened
uh and uh here fabi again has to decide
whether he wants to play this passively
with something like rook to c2 then rook
to d3 can come
or does he want to try and uh still get
back into the game and and grab this
pawn
maybe he can do it like this uh he
decides to grab the pawn but now comes
bishop to d5 and this is one a very
important
uh in between move before actually
grabbing the c3 pawn
so a nice bishop to d5 switching to and
now what do you do here
uh the rook has to move we have rook to
h4
but now comes uh the real problem for
fabi
rook captures on c3 and what do you do
now
there are no squares for the knight and
b6 will trap the knight there's no
no escaping that uh but fabi again
incredibly resilient he finds a way
rook to h7 now the threat is just uh to
pick up the b7 pawn so uh
mommy there was a movie comes really uh
it doesn't really come as a surprise
he plays b6 chases away this knight and
now
knight captures on c6 uh we have bishop
captures on c6 the rook cannot capture
as then
rook captures bishop and now comes rook
to c7 here fabi's idea is
i'm just going to play rook d6 check and
win back my my piece
uh but here we have rook to c1 king to
f2
and now rook to f8 and this rook to f8
is just a brilliant maneuver
point being that now if rook to d6 check
you don't get to win the bishop because
the king sidesteps with
check and that's it then then the bishop
can escape for example king to e3 we're
going to play rook to c3 with check
and after king to d2 rook to a3 so okay
you can win the bishop
uh rook captures here but now rook to f2
with check and what do you play
king the e1 and now rook captures on g2
and now uh when your king is in in this
kind of a situation where it's
just you know really being threatened by
everything uh just rooked
for example rook to h3 to h1 will be
checkmate uh white will have to spend
all of his moves trying to avoid
checkmate and then you're just gonna
pick up even more material and you're
already up two pawns so
this will be completely winning for him
so instead after rook to f8 we have b5
uh trapping the bishop right away but it
doesn't matter king to e6 with
check king to g3 and now rook to c3
with check king h2 now comes rook to h8
with
check and here we have kink the g1 and
now we get this position
uh where mamadirov has a beautiful
beautiful maneuver to win the game
but i'm not just going to show it to you
of course we'll figure it out all by
yourself
uh not using any uh you know
assistance so while i give you a couple
of seconds
i have at it
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this
uh beautiful maneuver and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to h1 with check that's the good
stuff and here
it doesn't matter what you do it simply
it doesn't matter rook
king captures on h1 was played in the
game i will however show what happens if
you sidestep this check uh
still black will just follow you rook to
f1 check he's going to say
take the rook and then of course after
you take the rook we're just going to
play bishop captures on g2
and then pick up the rook on c7 for
example rook caltrason g2 rook captures
on c7
uh and now you are up two pawns and it
doesn't matter you're going to win back
this pawn but
king f5 attacking the rook rook h6 and
now rook to c1 with
check king e2 now rook to a1 and now
these pawns will fall if rook to h4
defending the pawn
you just block it e4 and now after a few
more checks we're just going to hide
the king rook h5 checking 84 and now
these pawns will fall and you are simply
up too much material and you're going to
win the game
on the other hand if you sidestep with
king to f2 rook to f1 check
and now you sidestep again with king to
e2
then you just you know align yourself
with the bishop bishop to b5 check we
give up the bishop and then we again
pick up this guy here
so again uh king captures here and again
it's two
two points up completely winning so
after this rook to h1 check five he said
okay obviously i have to capture the
rook he played king captures on h1
and now bishop captures and g2 uh not
king captures rook captures was played
and now rook captures on c7
uh rook captures and g6 king to d5 and
now
again if you try and defend the a4 pawn
somehow maybe try
if you go here then we can just block it
if you go here with the idea of just
bringing the rook here
then we can even trade rooks right away
rook h7 check king here we're going to
deliver check and after the king moves
we're just going to trade here
and of course being up upon here
completely winning we're going to
eliminate these guys and that's it
so after king the d5 phobia tried one
last idea and that is a5
and now while you can play b characters
on a5 uh major of says nope i'm going to
show you how this is
uh uh you know played without even
thinking
yeah he plays king the c5 we have a
captures a captures and now rook the e6
by fabi going after the pawn
but mamadara in incredibly great style
gives it up he plays king cat person b5
rook captures on e5 with check and now
rook to c5 he says
that's it this is completely winning for
me because if fabi trades here just
captures captures king can also capture
doesn't really matter
and now the white king is simply too
slow we're gonna play c4 king f1
king f1 king f2 we're gonna play c3 and
now after king e2 we just bring the king
into the game
uh king to d1 we're gonna play king to
b3 and after king to c1 of course
c2 wins the game for uh for a player of
of their uh you know caliber this is the
the
this you don't even have to calculate
this this just plays by itself
so after rook the c5 fabio of course
cannot trade he plays rook to e1 and now
mommy thereof shows again
why it doesn't matter he plays rook to
g5
and uh well it was in this position on
48 that fabiano corona resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
point is that now the king is completely
cut off from the game
the black rook controls the g file
completely and that's it you
the white rook will not be able to stop
the king alone you will simply you know
sidestep the checks and then continue
pushing your pawn and that's it
the white king will just be a helpless
spectator for for the rest of the game
yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh like i said the last
round was a bit of a snooze fest so i
decided to show this one by the winner
of the tournament chakri armadyarov
and these are the standings uh of the of
the super bet uh
chess classic so mamadirov wins the
entire thing with six out of nine
incredible results without without a
single loss levon
uh trailing with five out of nine uh he
lost that game to mama jarv and that
really meant a lot as you can see here
uh grishok and wesley also with five out
of nine then anish giri and temur rajab
of uh both on four and a half out of
nine
uh both on fifty percent you know
perfectly balanced as as all things
should be
uh and then with three and a half we
have the the romanian uh superstars
lebelescu in the dark
and fabi and maxine bashar al-agrav with
three and a half also
uh uh oh sorry uh
i see the the the now i see the
standings
are not finished so uh it was still
being played so let me just quickly
check if they're still playing ah
yeah they're still playing fabi is still
playing doc in the
uh in the final round they're still
trying to to do it so uh
completely disregard this because uh
well uh for now
fabi and duck are are in wrong position
so it will be
uh half a point uh for both of them uh
so what what does that mean for us for
mamiya it doesn't really mean anything
he's first however you put it
but fabi could overtake um
perhaps overtake uh well uh both
uh diac and lupulescu if he somehow
manages uh
to to win this game but we'll see how it
goes but mavidorf wins it so
only watch the absolute top of the of
the
uh of the standings so yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it really
incredible preparation by mamedyarov
just uh you know completely uh busting
open a new position on move six with
that c6 idea and then just g5 i mean
beautiful stuff this is what we what we
always enjoy seeing uh so i hope you
guys
hope you guys enjoyed that so uh that's
the game
once again i hope you enjoyed it i would
like to thank happy birthday as paul
abhijit banerjeet san console of western
captor uh carpet cleaning in corporate
and
isa garuda for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of uh well
everything that is happening in the
chess world checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
uh and well probably most likely
continuing the morphe saga
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day